En ce qui concerne les inventions,
j'aimerais vous raconter l'histoire de l'un de mes projets préférés.
Il s'agit sans doute de l'un des plus passionnants sur lesquels je travaille,
mais c'est aussi, pour moi, le plus simple.
Ce projet est susceptible d'avoir des répercussions énormes dans le monde entier.
Il concerne l'un des principaux problèmes de santé de la planète,
la première cause de mortalité chez les enfants âgés de moins de cinq ans,
qui est... ? les maladies liées à l'eau ? la diarrhée ? la malnutrition ?
Non. Il s'agit de l'inhalation des fumées émanant des feux allumés en intérieur pour cuisiner,
et des infections respiratoires aiguës qu'ils provoquent. Incroyable, non ?
Pour moi, c'est à la fois choquant et révoltant.
N'est-il donc pas possible de créer des combustibles plus propres ?
Ne pouvons-nous pas fabriquer des poêles de meilleure qualité ?
Comment ce phénomène peut-il entraîner plus de deux millions de décès par an ?
Je sais que Bill Joy vous a parlé
des qualités exceptionnelles des nanotubes de carbone.
Je vais donc vous parler
de l'intérêt exceptionnel des macrotubes de carbone, c'est-à-dire du charbon.
Voici une photo de la campagne haïtienne : Haïti est aujourd'hui déforestée à 98 %,
et vous pourrez voir des paysages comme celui-ci dans toute l'île.
Cela crée des troubles environnementaux variés,
et des problèmes qui affectent les habitants dans l'ensemble du pays.
Il y a quelques années, une inondation assez grave a eu lieu
et a entraîné des milliers de morts ;
elle est directement liée au fait
qu'il n'y a pas d'arbres sur les collines pour maintenir la terre.
Et donc, lorsqu'il pleut, les fleuves débordent et provoquent des inondations.
Le manque d'arbres est lié au fait suivant :
les habitants doivent faire la cuisine, donc ils collectent du bois
et le transforment en charbon pour cuisiner.
Ne croyez pas que les habitants ignorent les dommages qu'ils occasionnent :
ils en ont parfaitement conscience mais n'ont pas d'alternative.
Les combustibles fossiles ne sont pas disponibles,
et cuisiner à l'énergie solaire ne permet pas de préparer les plats comme ils les aiment.
Voici donc ce qu'ils font :
vous verrez des familles comme celle-ci se rendre en forêt pour trouver un arbre,
l'abattre et le transformer en charbon.
Il n'est donc pas étonnant que beaucoup de travaux aient été menés
pour tenter de trouver des combustibles alternatifs pour la cuisine.
Il y a près de quatre ans, j'ai emmené un groupe d'étudiants à Haïti,
et nous avons travaillé avec des bénévoles du Peace Corps.
Voici l'un de ces bénévoles,
et voici le dispositif qu'il avait construit dans le village où il travaillait.
Il reposait sur l'utilisation de vieux papiers,
qui étaient compressés et transformés en briquettes susceptibles de servir de combustible.
Toutefois, ce procédé était très lent.
Les étudiants en ingénierie ont donc travaillé dessus
et, grâce à quelques changements très basiques,
ils ont réussi à tripler la capacité de ce dispositif.
Vous pouvez donc imaginer leur intérêt pour ce sujet !
Ils ont alors rapporté les briquettes au MIT afin de les tester,
et ils ont découvert, entre autres, qu'elles ne brûlaient pas,
ce qui a quelque peu découragé les étudiants.
Et, en fait, si vous regardez de plus près juste ici,
vous pourrez lire "U.S. Peace Corps."
En effet, il s'est avéré qu'il n'y avait pas de vieux papiers dans ce village.
Et s'il est vrai que pour ce volontaire, ramener de la papereasse
du gouvernement au village avec lui était une bonne idée,
il fallait quand même parcourir 800 kilomètres.
Nous avons donc pensé qu'il existait peut-être un meilleur moyen
de créer un combustible de cuisine alternatif.
Ce que nous voulions, c'est créer un combustible
utilisant des ingrédients facilement accessibles au niveau local.
Sur cette photo, on voit de petits moulins à sucre très répandus en Haïti.
Et les déchets de la production,
une fois le jus de la canne à sucre extrait, sont appelés "bagasse".
Ils n'ont aucune autre utilité, aucune valeur nutritionnelle,
et ne sont donc pas utilisés pour nourrir les animaux.
Ils sont juste empilés près du moulin à sucre, en attendant d'être brûlés.
Ce que nous voulions, c'était trouver un moyen d'exploiter
ces déchets et de les transformer en un combustible
avec lequel les habitants pourraient facilement cuisiner,
comme le charbon.
Durant les années suivantes, j'ai donc travaillé avec les étudiants pour créer ce procédé.
On prend la bagasse, et on la place dans un simple four
qui peut être fabriqué à partir d'un baril de pétrole vide de 210 litres.
Au bout d'un moment, après y avoir mis le feu, on le ferme hermétiquement
afin de limiter la quantité d'oxygène pénétrant dans le four,
et on finit par obtenir de la bagasse calcinée.
Cependant, on ne peut pas la faire brûler parce qu'elle est trop fine,
et qu'elle se consume trop rapidement pour une utilisation en cuisine.
Nous devions donc trouver une solution pour la transformer en briquettes utilisables.
Par chance, l'un de mes étudiants était ghanéen,
et il s'est souvenu d'un plat nommé "kokonte" que lui préparait sa mère,
un porridge très épais à base de racine de manioc.
Nous avons donc mené des recherches et découvert que
le manioc était également cultivé en Haïti,
En réalité, cette racine est cultivée dans le monde entier :
yucca, tapioca, cassave, manioc, c'est la même chose,
un légume-racine très riche en amidon.
On peut en faire un porridge très épais et collant,
qui peut être utilisé comme liant dans les briquettes de charbon.
C'est ce que nous avons fait : nous sommes partis pour Haïti.
Voici les diplômés de la première Ecole de Charbon,
ou "Charcoal Institute" en anglais. Et ces...
(rires)
-- voilà. En fait j'enseigne au MIT et au CIT.
Et voici les briquettes que nous avons fabriquées.
Je vous emmène maintenant sur un autre continent : voici l'Inde,
et voici le combustible le plus utilisé en cuisine : la bouse de vache.
Plus encore qu'à Haïti, les feux allumés avec cet élément produisent énormément de fumée,
et les répercussions sur la santé sont vraiment manifestes,
lorsque la bouse de vache ou la biomasse sont utilisées comme combustible pour cuisiner.
Les principales victimes sont les enfants et les femmes,
parce que ce sont eux qui sont présents autour de ces feux.
Nous avons donc voulu voir si nous pouvions introduire
ce procédé de fabrication du charbon en Inde.
Malheureusement, ils n'avaient ni canne à sucre
ni manioc, mais cela ne nous a pas découragé.
Nous avons donc cherché à connaître les ressources locales en termes de biomasse.
Dans cette zone, on trouvait de la paille de blé et de la paille de riz.
Comme liant, nous avons pensé utiliser
de petites quantités de fumier de vache
qui sert habituellement de combustible.
Nous avons réalisé des essais comparatifs et vous pouvez voir ici
les briquettes de charbon, et là, la bouse de vache,
et on voit bien que les briquettes brûlent beaucoup plus proprement.
En réalité, ce combustible permet de faire chauffer l'eau bien plus rapidement.
Nous étions donc très satisfaits.
Cependant, nous avons découvert
lors des essais comparatifs avec le charbon de bois,
que notre charbon brûlait moins longtemps, et que les briquettes s'effritaient quelque peu,
ce qui entraînait une perte d'énergie lors de la cuisson.
Nous avons donc tenté de trouver une solution pour fabriquer des briquettes plus solides
de façon à rivaliser avec le charbon de bois vendu sur les marchés haïtiens.
Nous sommes retournés au MIT et, à l'aide de la machine Instron,
nous avons déterminé les forces nécessaires
pour comprimer une briquette jusqu'à obtenir
un meilleur résultat.
Et pendant ce temps, des étudiants travaillaient sur ce problème en laboratoire,
nos partenaires locaux travaillaient à Haïti sur le développement du procédé
afin de l'améliorer et de faciliter son accès pour les habitants des villages.
Et après un certain temps,
nous avons développé une presse à faible coût permettant de produire du charbon
qui brûle plus longtemps et plus proprement que le charbon de bois.
Nous disposons donc maintenant d'un produit qui est en réalité meilleur
que celui que l'on trouve sur le marché haïtien
et c'est extrêmement satisfaisant.
Rien qu'à Haïti, près de 30 millions d'arbres sont abattus chaque année.
Il est possible que ce procédé soit mis en place
et qu'une bonne partie de ces arbres puissent alors être sauvés.
En outre, les recettes obtenues grâce à ce charbon s'élèvent à 260 millions de dollars :
il s'agit d'une somme colossale pour un pays comme Haïti,
dont la population atteint huit millions de personnes
pour un revenu moyen inférieur à 400 dollars.
Et donc nous avançons avec notre "projet charbon",
et un élément que je trouve également intéressant,
est que l'un de mes amis de l'université de Berkeley a réalisé une analyse de risque.
Il a comparé les problèmes de santé occasionnés
par la combustion du bois et celle du charbon,
et il a découvert que dans le monde entier,
on peut éviter 1 million de morts en passant du bois au charbon
pour cuisiner. C'est impressionnant !
Cependant, c'était jusqu'alors impossible sans abattre d'arbres.
Désormais, nous disposons d'une solution
qui utilise un déchet agricole pour créer un combustible de cuisine.
Mais, un autre élément particulièrement intéressant
a surgi lorsque je me suis rendue au Ghana le mois dernier,
et je trouve que c'est vraiment génial.
Et c'est encore plus simple que ce que vous venez de voir,
imaginez vous. Voilà.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? Des épis de maïs transformés en charbon.
Et ce qui est merveilleux, c'est qu'il est inutile de façonner des briquettes.
Elles se forment naturellement. C'est mon "PC à 100 dollars" à moi !
Et, comme Nick (Negroponte), je vous ai apporté des échantillons.
(rires)
Nous allons les faire circuler.
Ils sont tout à fait utilisables, testés sur le terrain, prêts à être lancés.
Et l'un des éléments particulièrement intéressants à propos de cette technologie,
est que son transfert est particulièrement simple,
par opposition au charbon de canne à sucre,
pour lequel nous avons dû former les personnes à la fabrication des briquettes
et où il y a une étape supplémentaire pour la cuisson du liant,
alors que celles-ci sont déjà pré-formées.
Et c'est peut-être la chose la plus intéressante que j'aie jamais faite,
ce qui peut paraître une remarque triste sur ma vie.
(rires)
Mais une fois que vous le voyez, comme le font les personnes au premier rang là...
n'est-ce pas? oui, donc...
(rires)
-- voilà. Et ceci est un parfait exemple
de ce dont Robert Wright parlait avec ses "sommes non-zéro".
Il y a donc non seulement des avantages pour la santé,
des avantages pour l'environnement,
et c'est en outre un cas extrêmement rare
de situation comportant également des avantages économiques.
Les habitants peuvent produire leur propre combustible de cuisine à partir de déchets
et peuvent en tirer un revenu.
Ils peuvent économiser l'argent qu'ils allaient dépenser pour acheter du charbon,
et peuvent en produire plus pour le revendre sur le marché
à d'autres qui ne produisent pas le leur.
Il est vraiment rare qu'il n'y ait pas de concession à faire
entre la santé et l'économie ou entre l'environnement et l'économie.
Je trouve donc ce projet particulièrement intéressant
et je suis vraiment impatiente de voir où il va nous mener.
Ainsi, lorsque nous parlons du futur que nous allons créer,
je pense qu'il est vraiment nécessaire d'avoir
une vision claire de notre monde actuel.
Et je ne parle pas du monde dans lequel nous vivons actuellement,
mais de celui où les femmes passent deux à trois heures par jour
à moudre du grain pour nourrir leurs familles.
Je parle du monde où les matériaux de construction de pointe
sont des tuiles en ciment faites à la main,
et où travailler dix heures par jour
ne vous rapporte que 60 dollars par mois.
Je parle du monde où les femmes et les enfants passent 40 milliards d'heures par an à chercher de l'eau :
c'est comme si toute la main d'œuvre de la Californie travaillait
à temps plein pendant un an avec pour seule activité la recherche d'eau.
Un monde où, par exemple, si nous étions en Inde,
trois personnes dans cette salle seulement posséderaient une voiture.
Un monde où, si nous étions en Afghanistan,
une personne seulement dans cette salle saurait utiliser Internet.
Un monde où, si nous étions en Zambie, 300 d'entre vous seraient agriculteurs,
100 d'entre vous seraient atteints du SIDA ou porteurs du HIV,
et plus de la moitié d'entre vous vivraient avec moins d'un dollar par jour.
Voici les problèmes auxquels nous devons trouver des solutions.
Voici les questions sur lesquelles nous devons former nos ingénieurs,
nos créateurs, nos hommes d'affaires et nos entrepreneurs.
Et ce sont ces réponses que nous devons apporter.
Pour moi, certains domaines en particulier doivent être traités,
et l'un d'entre eux est la création de technologies en faveur de la micro-finance et des micro-entreprises,
afin que les personnes vivant en dessous du seuil de pauvreté puissent s'en sortir
grâce à d'autres solutions que
la traditionnelle fabrication de paniers, l'élevage de volailles, etc.
Mais il existe de nouvelles technologies et de nouveaux produits
qui peuvent être produits à petite échelle.
L'autre chose en laquelle je crois, est la nécessité de créer des technologies pour les agriculteurs pauvres
afin qu'ils puissent faire augmenter la valeur de leurs cultures.
Nous devons repenser nos stratégies de développement,
de façon à ne pas promouvoir des campagnes
incitant les agriculteurs à arrêter leurs activités,
mais les incitant plutôt à cesser d'être des agriculteurs pauvres,
et concevoir des stratégies pour que cette démarche soit efficace.
Nous devons travailler avec les membres de ces communautés,
et leur fournir les ressources et les outils qui leur permettront
de résoudre leurs problèmes. C'est la meilleure solution,
il ne faut pas agir de l'extérieur.
Nous devons donc créer ce futur, et commencer dès aujourd'hui.
Merci.
(applaudissements)
Chris Anderson : Pourriez-vous -- pendant que nous regardons s'il y a des questions --
nous parler d'un autre projet sur lequel vous avez travaillé ?
Amy Smith : Parmi les autres sujets sur lesquels nous travaillons,
figure notamment l'étude de la réduction du coût des tests de la qualité de l'eau,
afin que les communes puissent gérer leurs propres systèmes d'approvisionnement en eau,
vérifier qu'ils fonctionnent, être capables de réaliser les traitements, etc.
Nous travaillons également sur des systèmes de traitement de l'eau à faible coût.
L'un des projets les plus intéressants a trait à la désinfection solaire de l'eau
et l'amélioration des possibilités d'un tel traitement.
CA : Quels sont les obstacles que vous rencontrez ?
Devez-vous trouver des entrepreneurs ou des partenaires financiers ?
De quoi avez-vous besoin pour mener à bien votre projet ?
AS : En effet, beaucoup d'acteurs sont impliqués.
C'est difficile, il s'agit d'un marché très fragmenté
et d'une population sans revenus.
Il est donc impossible d'utiliser un modèle américain
pour faire avancer les choses.
En outre, l'équipe est assez réduite : c'est moi.
(rires)
Donc je fais ce que je peux avec les étudiants :
chaque année nous envoyons 30 étudiants sur le terrain,
qui tentent de mettre en œuvre ces projets et de les faire avancer.
Il faut aussi tenir compte de la longueur des délais car, vous vous en doutez,
on ne peut s'attendre à atteindre un tel objectif en un ou deux ans :
il faut fixer des objectifs sur cinq ou dix ans.
Néanmoins, je pense qu'avec une telle vision, nous pouvons progresser.